dmca a terrifying four letter acronym
that strikes fear into the hearts of
content creators on the internet it
seems like whenever a DMCA takedown
strikes the internet goes into a panic
the latest example of this was when
popular youtuber PewDiePie uttered a
racist slur during a live stream this
pushed Firewatch developer Campo Santo
to issue takedowns and remove his videos
featuring the studio's game to some a
DMCA may seem like the simple removal of
a piece of content but to creators it's
something much more impactful there's no
question that what PewDiePie did was
indefensible
however Campo Santos actions have caused
quite the stir even pushing some to
flood Firewatch with negative reviews on
Steam all of this leaves me with
multiple questions was campo santo and
it's right to do what it did what
exactly does the DMCA mean to a youtuber
does this mean a company could take
advantage of it in more nefarious ways I
asked videogame attorney Ryan Morrison
to explain some of this to me and he
says that what Campo Santo did was
completely legal though that doesn't
necessarily mean he agrees with it
[Music]
well so what what kept Santo did is
entirely legal
even though not everyone likes that
including myself I don't think the law
is right or caught up to date with
technology but it's the law right now
any developer can shut down any
letsplayer very easily unless that less
player has a formal non revocable
license and even in that instance what
PewDiePie said would trigger most even
non revocable licenses to be revoked
there's usually a morality clause
attached to it so even in that case he'd
probably be screwed here but generally
throughout the Internet of let's play
videos that entire industry is legally
infringing right now would I argue fair
use for it absolutely would I be the
first lawyer to sign up if if a let's
play video was taken down over something
like this
absolutely but the way the law is
sitting right now it's it's difficult to
say to any client who comes to me about
this anything other than yes as a let's
player you are infringing and you need
permission from the developer to stream
their game
speaking of permission many have noted
that far watches website says that
you're allowed to stream the game and
monetize the videos however Morrison
pointed out to me that because it
doesn't say anything about the license
it defaults to being revocable and so
Campo Santo was able to revoke
PewDiePie's license now I won't argue
against Campo Santo reasons for removing
the content however let's say there's a
let's player whose opinion of a game is
less than positive a rogue developer
could legally have those videos taken
down thanks to the DMCA with little
recourse available to the content
creator and if a developer wished to
take further advantage of the system and
issue several notices to a single
youtuber it could put that person at
risk of having their channel shut down
professional let's player Ryan Latour no
better known as northernlion let me in
on exactly what happens when these
notices are issued and just how serious
it is so the way that it works on the
YouTube side is that the first DMCA
there called copyright or content strike
so the first copyright strike that you
get via DMCA comes with punishments like
temporarily you are disabled for
monetization and you have to go through
a program that they've set up called
copyright school where they teach you
all about what you can and cannot use on
YouTube and then if you get more of
those there's like extreme
even punitive damages that you could
face like being restricted from
uploading over a certain videos over a
certain length or you know may be
permanently disabled monetization all
the way through to like channel closure
but the problem right now is that
there's really only allow everything or
issued the MCAS there's no in between
and the DMCA is catastrophic for a
YouTube channel basically so because
there's no middle ground right now it's
all or nothing and that's why I think
that a lot of youtubers were made
anxious by this situation is because the
the DMCA is really like quite a damaging
thing and and if it's abused or used too
frequently it could potentially destroy
somebody's career over something that I
think most people would probably feel
like your career should not be destroyed
over in the sense that your claim
somebody else's video game thankfully
for him northernlion has never received
a takedown notice his most popular
content focuses largely on games like
Binding of Isaac
XCOM and player unknowns battlegrounds
these types of games are different every
time you play them which Northern Line
says allows for videos that make the
viewers want to play the game themselves
of course that's not always the case
with Let's Plays story focused games
like that dragon cancer we're said to
have lost sales because of videos that
showed the whole game though it is worth
pointing out some people may have never
heard of it without those Let's Plays
this is where some developers ask people
to hold off on streaming the entire
experience of course there are some
studios that are totally okay with full
playthroughs Campo Santo being one of
them these developer conditions aren't
always the same for every game and video
much like fair use Morrison told me that
PewDiePie could take his Firewatch
situation to court and argue that his
videos are in fact fair use but even if
he succeeded
it wouldn't spell victory for all let's
players fair use is determined on a
case-by-case basis and legal fees aren't
cheap not every youtuber can afford to
go to court over a video and even if
they could the legal process could take
years before anything is resolved
Morrison however believes he has a
better solution nothing is fair use
until a judge or jury says it is and
just be even if this went to court and
he got a pass and and the judge said
Felix see this
is fair use good job that would mean
that this instance was fair use not that
let's play videos or fair use there is
no line like that you have each each
instance is gonna have to be examined
and what I think we should do instead as
an industry is work on proper licensing
and proper policing within our own
industry we see that in video games the
ESRB the guys who put the ratings on
those video games that was done by a
private group of video game
professionals who decided we're gonna
regulate ourselves so the government
doesn't come in and regulate us for us
so what I think we need to see happen is
it is a private group here that comes
out with a bunch of regulations for
streamers and devs can sign up to have
their game through that and then they
can't just revoke a license like this if
they're part of that Alliance or group
or whatever you want to call it the
early 90s saw the government going after
video games for violence and
inappropriate content most notably in
games like Mortal Kombat and night trap
political hearings were held and
executives from Sega and Nintendo argued
over who was handling content like this
properly Sega had its own rating system
while Nintendo chose to censor and bar
certain content from appearing on its
consoles
sadly the government didn't think either
method was sufficient so it threatened
to regulate video games itself that's
when a bunch of publishers including
Sega and Nintendo joined together and
formed the ESRB which allows users to be
informed of what type of content of
video game holds in addition to
permitting publishers and developers to
make games without government meddling a
similar approach is what Morrison
believes would work best for creators
developers and publishers when it comes
to streaming and videos on YouTube but
why would publishers join a middleman
organization
well Morrison explained to me how such
an operation could work companies would
join put its games on a safe list and
agree to certain regulations this could
allow let's players the freedom to
express their opinion freely without
fear of takedowns but it could also mean
that publishers and developers wouldn't
have to deal with legal headaches or
streamers inappropriate actions another
benefit for studios is that they
wouldn't be the ones taking videos down
which could very well lead to a decrease
in harassment on social media and review
bombing of course this isn't actually
happening at the moment and as far as we
know there are no plans to create such
an organization this is simply just one
idea for a problem that desperately
a solution there's no doubt that the
DMCA is important it protects the rights
of copyright holders and ensures that
their properties aren't stolen or used
illegally however it shouldn't be used
for shutdowns that are motivated by non
legal issues it's crucial that lets
players critics and journalists are
allowed to speak their mind free from
the fear of being shut down by a tool
that is meant for copyright violations
and that above all is why fixing this
problem is so important
[Music]